And Mail message from your local nerd
writer.
Oh,
sorry,
didn't see you there.
Hi,
I'm the nerd writer and this week I'm on
my 52nd blog.
That's a year's worth of logs.
So it's sort of a special occasion.
So what I'm going to do is a question
and answer blog.
Now people have asked me a lot of stuff
in the comments before and I've never
really answered anything outright.
So here's your chance.
Ask me anything you want in the comments
of this video.
And next week I'll do a vlog where I
answer as many as I can.
Also,
if you haven't watched my blog from last
week a block,
51 New York City,
please do and vote for me and my
destination dot coms.
The biggest,
baddest bucket list.
If you think it would be cool to see me
show you and teach you the world,
I think it would be pretty cool.
Um,
well actually I'd love to stay and talk
more,
but I have a prior engagement.
So ask your questions.
I'll see you next time.